istres la hausse du prix de
l'électricité le kilowattheure sera
bientôt plus cher pour nous
consommateurs motif
la commission européenne impose
d'augmenter la part des énergies
renouvelables dans la production
d'énergie globale
elles sont évidemment plus cher david
boeri frédéric de la rue payer un peu
plus cher de l' électricité plus propre
dans cette agence edf
les clients ne sont pas tous prêts à
faire un effort au nom de l'écologie qui
s'est fort un petit effort c'est
difficile
bon ça dépend quel effort savez on n'est
jamais d'accord pour payer un peu plus
cher hein tu vois pas pourquoi je tenais
plus pour vous emmener en santé nous
d'ici 2010 la france est engagée à
produire 21 % de son électricité à
partir d'énergies renouvelables de
l'énergie solaire éolienne ou
hydraulique pour respecter cet
engagement
edf va devoir investir sa demande pour
amortir ces investissements qu'edf
rachète le prix du courant un tout petit
peu plus cher que le courant qu'elle
produit et donc ça se traduira dans
quelques années mais pas maintenant par
une augmentation très très faible de
prix de l'électricité l'électricité
produite par une éolienne coûte
aujourd'hui deux à trois fois plus cher
que dans une centrale nucléaire en 2010
l'éolien devra représenter 6 % la
production électrique en france